let's go to Marcus from Sacramento
Marcus from Sacramento welcome to the
program what can I do for you today
Marcus from Sacramento you're muted by
your own doing please unmute yourself
and then you'll be able to talk to me
hello David hi
hey so I'm uh I'm obviously from
California and I'm a big fan of uh Gavin
Newsom our governor and he said a few
months ago that uh it's time for us to
kind of stop with the whole they go low
we go high routine
um how do you feel about uh Democrats
becoming more I guess ruthless just like
the Republicans are in order to get uh
things done I played the clip of Gavin
Newsom saying that when he said it I
completely agree with it now when I when
I talked about this I made a sort of a
distinction I guess I would say Marcus
which is I don't think
that what Democrats need to start doing
is lying deceiving cheating criminality
like we shouldn't be stooping to what
the right is doing but when it comes to
being ruthless with regard to using
stronger language adopting particular
tones targeting with aggressive ads when
when Republicans have done things all
these all the things that Newsome is
suggesting
we we absolutely should do it I don't
believe that that is quote stooping to
their level I think stooping to their
level would be overtly lying to try to
get policies passed that are terrible
for the American people but good for
their friends right like that's what
they do we shouldn't do that but when it
comes to language tone and strategy in
the way that Newsome is suggesting
ruthlessness I'm with it a hundred
percent
I said one last question um we're
noticing lately people like Tucker
Carlson Ben Shapiro they're trying to
essentially downplay uh January 6 and
yeah my thoughts are
um that they uh that January 6 is
working like our strategy of using
January 6 is working and uh they're
starting to go hey we need to downplay
it because it's just it's an effective
strategy yeah how do you feel about
using that I think to some degree that's
true but at the same time the longer it
is since the January 6 Trump riots I
think the more diminished the
effectiveness will be I don't for
example I don't know that in 2024
talking about the Trump riots will be
super effective for whoever is
ultimately the Democratic nominee I may
be wrong about that but I feel like its
power will be will diminish over time
awesome well thank you so much for
having me on what's going on in the
background by the way Marcus do you run
a daycare are those your kids
I'm a work from home stay at home dad so
sorry about that no no no no problem it
sounds uh sounds active for lack of a
better term
yeah there are five and and two right
now so it's uh it's it's really fun so
all right I take your word for it sounds
hectic but uh someday I might be there
all right Marcus thank you for the call
thank you Dave ticker all right there it
goes Marcus from Sacramento